if I'm going to rule in Westeros I'll
need to make alliances the best way to
make alliances is with marriage
how are you marrying this time I don't
know maybe no one but you need to do
over the noble house to the table are
you a queen of fish bait what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
talking thrones today's video will be a
little bit different than usual this
will not necessarily be a prediction or
Theory video but more or less a
discussion video there is something that
I want to talk to you about because I
want to see what all of you have to say
about this I love hearing from all of
you and I respect everyone's opinion
even if they disagree with me sometimes
so feel free to leave your thoughts down
below after this video I have made a few
other videos about potential marriages
in the near future but in this one I
want to go straight to the top and talk
about the possibility of Daenerys
Targaryen getting married as you can see
from the clip I showed at the beginning
of this video Daenerys Targaryen will be
in Westeros very soon and she has
already accepted the fact that she may
have to get married once again
she told Daario that if she was going to
rule Westeros then she's going to have
to make alliances and we all know that
the best way to make an alliance is
through marriage and personally I used
to think Daenerys would need to get
married ever again because she does have
a massive force right now and she has
three dragons that are going to be damn
near the size of airplanes but after
seeing tons of photos promos and
trailers it appears that Daenerys will
lose a significant amount of her forces
this season Daenerys will be in an
all-out war during most of the season
she's going to lose men at sea she's
going to lose men at Casterly Rock and
she's going to lose men during the field
of fire now she will most likely win all
of those battles but not without taking
some significant losses and there is a
very good chance she may lose a dragon
now I know that might be hard for some
of you to believe but dragons can die
and most likely will die there are going
to be so many battles during season
seven it's going to be insane so there
may come a time that Daenerys will need
to make some kind of marriage alliance
and this wouldn't be the first time
and that Damaris had to do this but who
will she marry when she gets to Westeros
if she marries anyone if she's going to
marry anyone it will have to be someone
else in a position of power that may
have an army or some influence over a
region of Westeros because I don't think
she would even consider someone from a
smaller house but if you disagree then
let me know down below but from what
we've seen in the television show I
don't think we're going to be seeing any
more Martell airs that she could
possibly even marry I don't think we're
going to be seeing any more Tyrell heir
she can marry either and I don't think
she will be marrying any tarly's in the
near future and I'm not even sure if she
would ever marry a Lannister either she
did make Tyrion her hand of the Queen
Tyrion may even be attracted to her but
I don't know if Daenerys would make that
move and as of right now Jaime Lannister
is her enemy from what we've seen in the
most recent trailer it looks like Jaime
will be going head-to-head with Daenerys
her dragon and the crazy-ass Dothraki
Army so I doubt she would marry Jaime
either even if he wanted to there is one
person that did talk about marrying
Daenerys though and that was Euron
Greyjoy
during the Kingsmoot he had this master
plan of Marin Daenerys and with her and
her dragons they would conquer Westeros
but that plan was spoiled rather quickly
when Yara in Theon took off with his
ships and sailed to marine to forge an
alliance of their own with Daenerys
Targaryen and as we've seen in the
season seven trailers it appears that
your honor is going to strike some of
Danny's fleet because of this and take
out a few of her new alliances so you're
on and Daenerys getting married is
completely out of the question
I don't think Daenerys will ever marry
Theon either and I'm sorry Britt I know
you want to see Theon shine but marrying
Theon wouldn't be the right move
I don't think marrying Theon would
strengthen her position in Westeros at
all and it's not like the Greyjoy's are
this beloved house throughout Westeros
anyway plus the Greyjoy fleet is about
to get destroyed out at sea so they
won't even be able to provide any more
men or ships right now either unless
they can call your own ship maker who
seems to know how to build a thousand
ships in one off season but other than
that I don't think so
but what about good old sweet Robin he
is Lord of the Vale and he has his own
castle and army he has an army that can
also fight in the snow
is a good thing considering winter is
here and the night king is coming now we
own a little finger more or less
controls the army but Robin is the lord
of the Vale does anyone think Daenerys
would ever consider marrying Robin I
don't think so I mean not only is he a
little boy still but he's a sickly
little boy who most likely won't survive
much longer I don't see Robin making
until the end but I could be wrong about
that
and if Robin did die and Littlefinger
had complete control over the Vale I
wouldn't put it past Littlefinger to try
and weasel his way onto Daenerys his
side but even if that were possible I'm
not so sure Daenerys would even consider
marrying Littlefinger either although he
is a very powerful man he doesn't have
the best reputation
I think Tyrion would highly suggest her
not to do that but who knows crazier
[ __ ] has happened there is someone else
that we may see again who is also an
eligible bachelor
what about ginjury obviously we haven't
seen ginjury in a very long time but if
he comes back into play does anyone
think he could potentially be
legitimized as of right now the
Baratheon house is damn near extinct now
that Robert Stannis and Renly are dead
we haven't seen anyone else in the show
at least who can carry on the Baratheon
name even all of Circe's kids are dead
even though they weren't real
Baratheon's they did have the Baratheon
name if Gendry comes back he could be
legitimized by Daenerys and he could
even be given the Stormlands now most of
you should know what I would like if
ginjury comes back and marries anyone I
would want it to be Arya I think that
would be a perfect match but that might
be too happy of an ending for Game of
Thrones standards and we still don't
know if Arya will even change her mind
about settling down with anyone as of
right now it doesn't look like it but
what do you all think
could you see Daenerys and ginjury being
a couple if he came back and was
legitimized I don't think that would be
too bad of a match but the Baratheon's
have lost all of their powers so I can't
say if that would be the best move or
not either in Jon Snow also knows how
close Ned and Robert were so he did have
some respect for the Baratheon's not to
mention John and Stannis did have a
respectable relationship as well so if
ginjury came back into the plot I could
see John wanting to legitimize him as
well so that the house doesn't die off
plus John knows what it's like to be a
bastard but these are just my opinions
but I have always felt
that if Gendry came back he would be
made a Baratheon in the end but let's
move on let's get to the big one since
we're speaking about Jon Snow what do
you all think about him and Daenerys
getting married I know this can be a
touchy subject for some people because
of many different factors but let's
discuss it a little bit I know there are
people who really want to see this
happen John and Daenerys are arguably
the two most popular characters in the
show some people even say that if John
and Daenerys had a child together that
it would be the prince or princess that
was promised but on the other hand there
are people that do not want to see this
happen we found out last season that
John has Targaryen blood which makes him
and Daenerys related Daenerys is
actually Jon Snow's aunt since Damaris
and Rhaegar were brother and sister in
Rhaegar was John's father now I know
some of you don't agree with that but in
the television show
Rhaegar is John's father HBO confirmed
that John's father was a Targaryen but
if you believe his father is someone
else in the books that's completely fine
but save that argument for another video
but when it comes to incest and
Targaryen this is something that they
have practiced to keep the bloodlines
pure so if John and Daenerys did get
together it wouldn't be completely out
of the ordinary for something like that
to happen this story also exposed us to
incest at the very beginning with Jamie
and Cersei so I won't be surprised if it
continued but you have to wonder how Jon
and Daenerys would feel about this as
individuals if Jon and Daenerys did
become attracted to each other which
they most likely will would they be
comfortable going forward with a
physical relationship if they knew they
were related
Daenerys might not mind as much since he
is a Targaryen and she is familiar with
her family's history but I don't know if
Jon would be able to accept that we know
the rumor about Jaime and Cersei is well
known throughout the Seven Kingdoms and
damn near everyone looks down upon that
or makes fun of the fact that they had
an incestuous relationship so with Jon
Snow being a man of the north and living
by the northern values I can't say he
would be up for something like that but
Jon may start a relationship with her
before he ever finds out they are
related what if Jon Snow never finds out
who his father is
that is a possibility rumours have also
been going around that Jon and Danny
will have sex next season so if that's
true and they start a physical
relationship with each other then it may
not matter too
them that they are related if they found
out afterwards but who knows what they
would think but let's forget about all
that and just think about this marriage
from a political standpoint do you think
it makes sense for them to get married
if Daenerys does lose the majority of
her army during these battles and
potentially lose a dragon she will need
to strengthen her position in Westeros
in marrying the king in the north would
certainly do that as of right now John
Snow is king in the north and he has the
full support of all the northern houses
on his side well except for little
[ __ ]
but Daenerys come into Westeros and
marrying the king would be a powerful
move the north is larger than all the
other kingdoms combined and if she plans
on defending herself against the knight
king in his army she's going to need a
man with experience on her side but one
thing that will be interesting to see
this season will be John's position in
the north will John be able to keep a
firm grasp on all the northern houses
when John leaves to meet Daenerys this
could end up being a turning point with
his title songs and Littlefinger will be
left at Winterfell and I know some
people think Sansa already has an issue
with John being named the king and we
all know Littlefinger doesn't want John
to be king but there is also another big
factor about to show up which is brand
stark brain stark is about to make it
back to Winterfell and he is the last
living male stark could bran play a role
in John losing his title as king
personally I don't think so in my
opinion bran has more important things
to focus on but I know some people
disagree with that but either way it
will be interesting to see how things
play out there will be some incredible
battles taking place next season not to
mention the impending doom from north of
the wall but the politics of Westeros
aren't quite done yet which will
definitely affect Daenerys and John but
what does everyone else think do you
think Daenerys Targaryen will get
married again and if you do do you think
she will marry or who do you want her to
marry is there anyone I left out that
you think is a possible candidate for
that role let me know down below and
before I go I have to give a huge shout
out something amazing happen once again
in a new record has been set for the
channel today I got an incredible amount
of money donated to the channel from PJ
also known as Pamela Mala Mala I hope I
didn't butcher that but
she donated $100 and I have to thank you
so much I never expected anyone to ever
donate to the channel so when someone
pledges a big amount like that I am
always so surprised and so grateful and
thankful for that this is why I love all
of you the feedback I receive in the
comment section the subs the views the
likes and everything else I really
really appreciate it and I am really
looking forward to experiencing this
entire season with you all so thanks for
coming along for the ride and I'll see
you all down below bye